ist es tatsächlich in bestehenden
gebäuden der fall dass die gut gesichert
sind so dass das wir in deutschland
bestandsbauten haben die aufgrund dieses
unfalls geldhauses das feuer enthalten
überprüft wurden wo dann auch
festgestellt wurde dass materialien
verbaut wurden die in bestimmten fällen
vielleicht einen eine brandgefahr
darstellen gründen sie muss man sagen
und hier gab es gerade auch in
nordrhein-westfalen adhoc sperrungen von
von gebäuden und wo menschen dann
aufgrund von brandgefahr das gebäude
verlassen mussten
das ist eine eine präventionsmaßnahme
gewesen um ein solches szenario in
deutschland gar nicht erst entstehen zu
lassen so und in vielen vielen städten
sind viele viele hochhäuser kontrolliert
worden und bei den allermeisten
hochhäusern so dass das die
bauvorschriften eingehalten wurden und
dass diese bauten ja man kann sagen
zumindest als als sicher gelten können
ich glaube eine hundertprozentige
sicherheit kann es in keinem fall geben
es gibt immer wieder irgendwelche
möglichkeiten die dazu führen können
dass auch ein großbrand innerhalb eines
eines wohngebäudes eines hochhauses
geben kann so und davor ist eben keine
stadt der welt gezeigt das kann in
hamburg in bewegt in ulsan passieren in
thiede in dieser schlimmen verheerenden
ausprägung glaube ich allerdings dass es
so in deutschland nicht vorkommen wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren